(upbeat music)
- Welcome back to another
"Addy Hour" episode.
Of course, it's my pleasure
to be able to continue these conversations
on a lot of different topics,
which I feel are really important
for so many aspects of our lives.
And today, we're really honored
to be able to jump into a topic
around children and youth.
So really think about the next generation.
And again,
something that I think is
very relevant for all of us,
no matter at what level
we interact with those
in the generations coming up.
So today,
I'm honored to be able to
welcome Dr. Michele Borba,
who is an internationally
renowned educational psychologist
who has published over 20 books.
One of those books includes
"UnSelfie, Why Empathetic Kids Succeed
In Our All-About-Me World."
Michele is an expert in parenting,
bullying and character development.
And she's spoken to over
one million participants
on five continents.
So someone who has
definitely gotten around
and just really used
that to inform her work.
She's a regular NBC contributor
who appears regularly on Today.
She's also been featured
as an expert on "Dateline",
"The View", "Dr. Phil",
"NBC Nightly News",
"Fox and Friends", "Dr. Oz",
and "The Early Show", among many others.
She also has a forthcoming book,
which we'll be talking about, as well.
And she lives in Palm Springs, California,
with her husband,
and is also the mother
of three grown sons.
So that's one thing that was
intriguing to me, as well.
Given your work, I would love to hear,
you know, to even meet
your sons at some point,
but that's a little bit of a tangent,
but again, just want to
welcome Dr. Michele Borba
to the "Addy Hour" podcast.
- Oh, thank you.
I have been so looking forward to this,
I'm gonna hire you as my new PR firm.
Thank you.
(Addy and Michele laughing)
- What a great intro!
- I would take that up.
Well, thanks so much for being here.
And again, the work
you do is so important.
- Oh, thank you.
- But as my listeners-
- Likewise, to you.
- Oh, I really appreciate that.
Definitely appreciate that.
As my listeners know, as well,
one of the things that we really
just value on this podcast
is the opportunity to kind
of peel back the layers
as it were, even as we
bring in so many experts.
So I did wanna start out just asking you
how you're doing at this moment,
with everything that's
going on in our world,
especially with the things
that have been unfolding
in Ukraine and Russia, as well?
- Well, I think I've been
sobbing my way through
the last three days with Ukraine.
I, I just,
the abomination is just extraordinary.
I have friends who adopted children
from Ukrainian orphanages.
The biggest concern right now
is trying to get ahold of them,
and they're trying to.
There's so many hundreds of
kids under the age of even four,
that they're trying to figure
out how to get 'em enough food
in order to get them across
a 20 mile, a 20-hour walk.
So that's been really hard,
but you know, when I,
the other thing though,
I have to keep telling myself
is look to the other side.
Otherwise I get too caught in Putin
and I look to the other side
and I saw images of
hundreds of shoes in Poland
and waiting for kids when
they got off the train,
take shoes or the people
in these other countries
with signs saying,
"Here I am, I've got a
place for you to stay."
That kind of a thing is just,
it gives you that...
there's that evil,
then, wow, is there
humanity if we look for it.
- Yeah, I think that's so well said.
We're seeing both sides
of humanity in that way.
And it's, I appreciate
you just sharing that.
Honestly, too, on, you know,
how you're navigating that
just to have a good place
for yourself, as well.
And I know that's something
that's near and dear to your heart
and something I've heard
you speak about as well,
even just the, and in terms
of compassion fatigue.
And I was just curious
about how for any of who,
I'm sure a lot of people
have heard that term,
but how's that actually
relate to the moment
that we're in, as you shared
so, so honestly about?
- I think we're all feeling it.
It's absolutely,
if there was one universal diagnosis,
it would be compassion fatigue.
And what is it?
It's, we all need relationships.
We all crave empathy.
And when social distancing kicked in
and we all had to be face-to-face
and we couldn't see
our family and friends,
that's what rejuvenates us.
In the other hand, what happened
was stress starts to build.
And when stress keeps building
and uncertainty is there,
you, where you often
dial your empathy down
and the outcome is compassion fatigue.
So when you see yourself being kind of,
"Oh, I'm not quite already there,
or your energy level is low",
what I'm really trying to do is read books
that I could get into and absolutely love.
I just finished "The Lincoln Highway"
and I fell in love with an
eight year old kid named Billy.
My gosh, is that kid resilient.
Or finding good fun movies
that you can see the good side.
I watch the news content
and try to turn it off
so that I can see a different view.
And I have been doing a
lot of Zooming with people
that I just really enjoy talking to,
'cause it helps me build up.
I think we all need to do that,
find what works for you,
'cause you have to keep your empathy up
and that stress level down.
- Yeah, yeah. So important.
And I feel like a lot of ways
we've been trying to be
creative about that as well.
Some of the topics that
we've even talked about
on this podcast have been around
just the importance of social bonding
and how that activates
oxytocin in our brains
and all those pieces.
And you know, whether that's
still there on Zoom or not,
but there's just a different energy
that comes from being in person.
But at the same time, like you said,
there are opportunities to be
able to connect with people
in ways that we hadn't done that before.
So appreciate you sharing
how you're navigating
that journey, as well.
- We just had to put
our creativity into it.
Well, that didn't work. So
what are we gonna do instead?
And if we keep, just keep
looking for the other options,
I think that's how we thrive.
- Yeah. Yeah.
And thrive, I'm glad you used that word,
'cause that's something we'll
definitely come back to.
(laughs)
Maybe that was an intentional, maybe not,
but as we think about
your new book, as well.
- No, it just is part of my,
this part of my vocabulary these days,
and what are we gonna do
to keep on doing and raising thrivers?
- Yeah. So important.
Before we jump there,
I just also wanted to hear a
little bit about your journey
for those who may be familiar with you
and those who aren't familiar to you,
how did you,
what started this passion
to get into this area of child development
in so many directions
that you've taken it?
- Absolute fluke.
I was a, I was a history major.
- Wow.
- And I came home to-
- I didn't expect that. (laughs)
- No, I came home to interview my dad
or just be with my dad
from college for a weekend.
And I'd never forget it.
You will appreciate this.
My dad was calm. He was cool.
You know, the world war II veteran,
the superintendent, he published books.
He was quite accomplished,
but he was so upset that day.
And he was holding a Newsweek magazine
and he was pacing the floor.
He looked at me and he
didn't expect my visit.
And the cover of the magazine
was "The First Three
Years of a Child's Life,
Make or Break Them."
He turned to me, pointed to it and said,
"Don't buy into this, Michele,
because if this were
true, I'd be dead today."
Now I sat there with my mouth open
because I didn't know anything
about my dad's parents.
The had passed away. I
never met my grandparents.
He sat me down and he said,
"This is what happened to me."
His parents apparently
came over very destitute,
no English from Italy,
tried desperately to be able to jumpstart
and wanted to give their
kids the best they could.
My dad was the youngest of five,
but my father, grandfather
went and became a coal miner
and then died when my dad was two.
- [Addy] Wow.
- And the only way that
his extremely loving mother
could afford the children
and keep them alive
was to put them in an orphanage.
- Hmm.
- So he said, my dad said,
"Okay, now I'm in an
orphanage. My mom is destitute.
I didn't know what was going on."
But he said, "It was
the people who saved me.
The nuns had such empathy for me, Michele.
That was the first thing, those nuns.
When they released me, my
mom got a little more money.
It was the local librarian
and she'd sneak books to me.
Danny would read this.
The neighbor next door would help me rake
and give me a little bit extra money.
A teacher would pull me aside and say,
'I think you could be a good writer.'"
He said, "My proudest moment was
when I got my scholarship
from Stanford and UC Berkeley,
to walk in and say, 'thank you very much'.
Don't buy into it, Michele.
People can make or break your life."
I went back and changed my
major to child development.
- Wow.
- So I was there,
found this amazing piece
of research by Emmy Warner.
And that started my whole career.
Emmy Warner substantiated
what my dad said.
She started to interview,
oh gosh, 40, just for 40 years,
she studied the same 700 children
who shouldn't have made it.
Extreme adversity in their life.
But one-third of them,
even by their teens
years was bouncing back
and she discovered the same thing,
caring people in their lives,
that would what my dad said.
And then somebody had taught
them protective buffers
or coping strategies.
That is a result they made it,
and that changed my whole career. Okay.
- Wow, wow.
- That is true.
That we gotta get this
information out to people.
- Yeah. That's such a powerful story
and I love that it has a
family connection as well.
And it sounds like just in that moment,
there was a shift and
a passion that emerged.
- Oh, it was an amazing shift.
And later on, he said,
"Michele, you should be
a special ed teacher.
That's how I ended up in special ed.
Everything I learned from every
part of my so-called career
was from kids.
They, it wasn't the textbook,
it was the kids who convinced me,
boy, this is doable stuff.
- Yeah. The hands-on,
real life experience.
Wow. Wow.
Definitely appreciate that.
And as you were,
as you were getting into the work,
how did do people respond
to you, were people...
'Cause in the same way,
it seems like there could
be a mixed reaction,
that either people would
be really excited about it
or did people ask you why,
why this route?
- Why this route?
You know, interestingly enough,
you're probably one of the few people
that asked why this route,
(Addy and Michele laughing)
so thank you very much.
I, my goal is...
Funny, I just took a very
slow path of a trajectory.
Whenever a phone call
would ring or something,
I went into a different director.
I got my masters in learning disabilities.
And then, I found this passion
for educational psychology.
That's where I got my doctorate.
I never planned to write a book,
but I had one of my
professors tell me I should.
And then once I wrote the book,
I never planned to be a speaker,
but somebody called up and
said, "We need you to speak."
So it was saying yes
to all of these little
avenues along the way
and I'm so glad I did.
- Yeah. And it seems like
it's tapped into your passion
that was already there too.
And so in a sense,
you were poised and ready for
the opportunities that came
because you're already
following that passion,
which I think is really
encouraging to hear.
- Well, I have no idea
on how critical it is
to find that passion, what's your joy,
what you just absolutely love to do.
And just helping kids and
working with families,
no matter where I am is my passion.
And I had the absolute,
amazing opportunity to work on.
I think five continents now.
I'm up to 23 countries.
- Wow.
- And what I've learned from
it is no matter where you are,
everybody has the same loves and concerns
and desires for their kids.
So it works no matter where we are,
let's all work together,
we're just all neighbors.
- Yeah. That's so important,
especially with everything we've been...
- Yeah.
- Walking through in
the last few years too,
would you say that, was
that a surprise to you?
Or do you think that you expected to,
to see that commonality?
- Well, travel has broken
every stereotype I had of life.
If we could all travel more,
it helps you, no matter where you are,
just be far more open
and realize they're just like
me, no matter where I am,
I don't care if it's religion, education,
you know, race, color, creed.
Oh, my gosh. People are wonderful,
with my best friends, I've
got them all over the world.
And I just got another call
from Abu Dhabi this morning
and said, "Can you come back?"
Oh, I'd love to come back.
- Wow.
It's just so fun.
- Yeah. That's so powerful.
I mean, it speaks to this,
the global community that
we have in the sense, too.
And even as you were sharing
about your dad's story,
just making me think about the community
that he had around him,
all those people who
are sewn into his life
in different ways and giving
him encouragement, the empathy,
the empowerment, I think
that's so critical,
and so encouraging to hear
that the way that you've
built that into your work,
even as one individual who has
traveled to all these places
and has learned so much
and is really sharing
that with so many of us.
- I love Susan Pinker's
book, "The Village Effect"
because she said, if you
really wanna boost empathy,
which is to me, the social glue
that holds us all together,
remember that villages of about 150 people
are the maximum of what kids really need
in order to create that community.
And what we've done is,
we've busted the villages
and we're these huge,
huge, suburban areas.
One of my favorite things to do is,
as I'm driving from, I don't care,
if it's Sri Lanka or New York,
I purposely go through an area
and I can go from a rural area,
drive through and I watch
the facial expressions
and they look like they're happy,
and the all of a sudden,
as I go into a bigger
area, in an urban area,
a little bit more stress comes in.
So maybe the first thing is we
just gotta capture each other
and realize we are the support system.
Let's get back to what we all need
for optimum mental health.
And as parents,
let's also look at what we're modeling.
Are we modeling thinking outside the box,
exposing our children to differences,
letting them be exposed
to how many wonderful other
opportunities they are.
You know, there's a great study
that also said, during the pandemic,
the kids who seem to fare a little better
were the kids who didn't
take the bus from New York
to their school,
but walked through the park in
order to get to their school.
Just those simple, ordinary things.
I'll mention one thing
when I was writing on resilience,
I've been trying to study this
for 40 years after my dad.
It's one of the best books I
also read was by Anne Maston.
She's from the University of Minnesota.
And what she did was she discovered
when she did the same thing
of kids growing up in extreme adversity,
is that ordinary things
can make extraordinary
differences on children's lives.
And when I looked at,
what do you mean by the ordinary things?
Like the walk through the park,
like prayer, like a sense of humor,
like a, some kind of a,
a talent or a hobby or an interest,
knowing I've got one friend.
And I looked at that and said,
that's what seems to be a problem,
what we've got is ordinary things
being removed a lot from
our children's lives
and maybe we just need to reboot.
- [Addy] Yeah.
- And it's not just the GPA
that's gonna help our kids in this world.
It's those ordinary
things that help fill them
and are going to be
really good decompressors
to help them get along with life.
- Yeah.
So many things that you
said that I'd love to unpack
and I'll pick a few,
but even as you're talking
about those ordinary things,
those small things, I
mean, as a neuroscientist,
even thinking about what we
understand about the brain
and having the brace
and just the things in our environment
that can bring us pleasure.
And even as we can engage
in our day-to-day activity,
talking that really can help us navigate
and just have a place of
mental health and wellness.
And I think oftentimes, we talk
about that in adult circles,
we don't always,
I think as much as we need to,
really think about that
for children and youth,
where it's even that much more important,
especially from a
developmental standpoint.
So it's great.
Great that you've been
paying attention to that
and to elevate that as well.
- Oh, you know,
one of the things that when you asked,
what am I looking forward to right now
is I'm finally being able
to get back on the road
and go and visit schools.
And the best thing I get to do
before I talk to the big school district
is do focus groups with teens.
- [Addy] Mmm.
- Oh, my gosh.
They just are so extraordinary.
Once they know whatever they say,
it's gonna be, there's no judgment,
just tell me.
So I've been trying to
figure out and ask them,
you know, what's causing
all of this stress
and what are the solutions for it?
And one kid, I just came
from college station, Texas.
He said, "We are so stressed.
But the thing is that nobody's
teaching us how to de-stress
and it doesn't,
isn't something you learn on a worksheet
and it's not like a one time health unit.
The big thing you guys,
you guys have gotta do,
is give us a repertoire of stuff,
and then we choose what works for us.
And then we have got to practice that
over and over and over and over
until we can do it without you.
I'm like, "Oh, my gosh,
textbook classic 101."
- That's so insightful.
(Addy and Michele laughing)
- I said,
so if you're gonna make us
do that deep breathing stuff,
that's cool.
But don't just tell us what it is,
every single day,
we should practice that
maybe two minutes a day.
- Mmm.
Yeah.
- That's exactly, we can
be doing that at home.
When we say we're so tired,
no, get two minutes a day.
Just practice one thing until
it becomes a new family habit.
I say that one
because one of the coolest
places I ever worked
was on army basis.
18 of them, and the
commanders kept telling me,
you should go talk to the Navy Seals.
I said, why.
He says it's because
we are retraining them
to get through some really
tough, adverse times
and I'm going, "That's for sure."
So when I asked the Navy Seal's I said,
"What are you guys doing?"
They said, "Three things,
and you better tell kids this,
'cause this is really helping us
and it's actually proven
to rewire our brains."
"Okay, what's one?"
"We figure out what our stress signs are
and we start pointing
it out to each other.
We don't wait till the meltdown.
We point 'em out.
Hey, you start grinding your teeth
or you start going like this,
or I can see, you know,
your heart hopping up and down.
We could do that to our kids.
Not that you're gonna get time out,
but just have you noticed,
that right before you
go to do the time test,
this is what you do."
Then they say, "We tell
ourself, chill out or relax.
And then we take a one-two breath,
slow two breath from our
abdomen, nothing new,
but it's slow two breath,
way like we're riding up an elevator,
keep focusing on the breath,
hold it and then slowly let it out.
So the exhale's twice
as long as the inhale.
And you see Berkeley says,
that's exactly what works.
- [Addy] Yeah.
- Why do we teach that to kids?
Doesn't cost a dime.
- Yeah. Yeah.
So important. And on that note,
I'm curious because even as you're talking
about the focus groups with the teens,
it seems like there's a push and pull.
I mean, even the, you know,
the kids that I've talked to in schools
and having kids myself too,
it seems like sometimes
there's just different places
that people are at.
So I'm curious what your view is of
where those mental health
conversations are for kids.
'Cause sometimes I get the sense
that the kids are thinking about it
more than the administrators
or the teachers,
and now to downplay the efforts
that the administrators and
teachers are putting in,
but seems like sometimes
there's a disconnect,
almost as if kids in youth
are more ready to move into it
than we give them credit for.
Now, I guess I'm answering
the question as I'm saying it,
but I'm curious if that's
been your perception.
- Oh, no,
I knew we would agree on anything
that comes outta your mouth
is gonna come outta mine.
And I think that's,
what's happening right now
is the pandemic aftermath.
We knew that it was going to
be a stressful for us all,
but now when we're looking at,
okay, now we can get back to normal.
I think we ought to put the red flag up
and go, "Really? What's
going on with the kids?"
The first thing that the kids
are saying that I had seen,
but they're now admitting,
their motivation is lower.
Their focusing abilities are lower
and this is the top performing kids.
These are, we're more irritable.
We can't handle the stress.
We're not sleeping as well as we used to.
So you put all that together,
the last thing you're
gonna be able to do is
they sit there for three
hours and keep going.
They said, you gotta
reinvent a little bit.
That homework load are
just astronomical on us.
We really are having a tough time
and we really need to know,
feel comfortable going in
talking to the counselors.
Many of the counselors have been,
they're wonderful, they said,
that they've been,
they've been really helping
us prior to coming in
with our GPAs and our getting to college.
- Mm.
- You want us to now open up
and tell them how upset we are
or how much in pain we are.
We got to build trust.
- Mmm hmm.
- I love the comments they came up with
because they're just, you know,
you could read any psychology book
and it's exactly the same thing.
- Exactly. Yeah, yeah.
- I think the first thing is
we are seeing a regression
in behavior patterns.
If I was to ask any teacher
or counselor or headmaster,
"What are you seeing?"
Kid regression,
more disrespect is coming up,
more, the whole society is disrespectful.
The adults have been behaving very badly.
I think it's spilling over to the kids.
But the second thing
is inability to really,
that motivation and the
perseverance isn't there.
But in all fairness,
you can't have the perseverance
unless you have the self-control.
Unless you have the confidence
and they all kind of work
together, as you know, so...
You have to start with where the kids are.
- Yeah. I think that's so, so well said.
One of the episodes we had recently was,
again, more on the counsel,
but some one who's an expert
in trauma informed teaching
and learning too.
And just acknowledging all the things
that the kids have gone
through and how, like you said,
that's going to affect their
actions in the classroom,
but not ignoring that,
and trying to just push beyond
about being aware of that too.
What do you say to parents
and teachers though?
'Cause I know sometimes the
comments that comes back,
the comments that come back, people say,
"Well, I'm here to teach.
I'm not a therapist.
I don't know how to navigate this."
And so even though,
as you're saying appropriately,
we need to push beyond just the GPA piece.
Sometimes people find that very difficult
to break outside of that.
Do you have tips that you try and share?
- Yeah, the most important thing
- In situations?
- For instance, I'm going
to Indiana tomorrow.
And what I'm trying to do is
when I talk to the teachers,
it's all about, I know you're teaching,
don't stop the lesson,
but let's find simple little
ways to weave in these things.
For instance, as you're talking,
you know that your kid's attention spans,
I don't care if they're
17 or three are shorter.
So take brain breaks.
And that is don't talk for 50 minutes,
instead, let's talk for 10 minutes
and then let's take a
30-second turn to your partner,
what's one thing you just heard?
You're gonna get more
retention from your kids
or just pick up your pencil
and draw one little thing
that the teacher just said,
that's one thing.
One of the best things I've
ever seen is quiet time
that's being done in the Oakland schools.
What they did brilliantly was shave off
one minute of each class time,
just one minute of each class time.
Now, you have five minutes
at the beginning of every single day,
five minutes at the beginning
of every single day,
every kid in the entire school
and the teachers do one-two breathing.
You can wedge if you want to,
half the kids are sleeping
for the first time.
You can choose meditation
if you choose to.
But here's the fabulous thing,
they've been tracking it.
Parties are going down.
Suspensions are going down.
Behavior problems are going down.
Test scores went through the roof.
They did absolutely nothing different
than let's just focus on
what the kids seem to need.
Let's teach them how,
let's have a counselor come in
and show you how to do a one-two breath.
And it made mind-boggling
like differences.
So it's not that you're stopping teaching,
- Exactly.
- It's that you're going
with where your students are,
trying to get them more
engaged because they're not.
They're also, by the way,
more risk adverse,
they're afraid to raise their hands.
They're really, social
anxieties up with our kids
'cause they've been facing
a screen for so long.
So a simple thing I also tell a teacher,
you can tell 'em at home.
First thing is Mary Budd
Rowe, brilliant researcher.
She said, you wanna ask a question,
ask the question,
then stop and pause,
and don't say anything for
at least three seconds.
'Cause the average one of us
says something immediately,
so what's the answer?
If you wait three seconds,
you'll get every kid to say something.
The kid who wouldn't have said anything
is gonna open his mouth and say,
you know, maybe a word.
The other kid who would've said something
is now gonna give you a dissertation,
but it's time to wait and
think can be critical.
And the final thing is our expectations.
Parents, it's like a rubber band.
Your goal was to figure out
what your kid is capable of,
right this minute.
If you don't know, ask the teacher,
but line your expectations up
and then gently keep
stretching him, gently.
Don't snap him 'cause
you'll snap his spirit,
but you keep stretching one step more
and one step more and one step more.
Just little things that's
using the research,
that don't mean it's another program,
but it means we can make a difference
on how our kids are more engaged,
better performers, better behavers
and their confidence will also go up.
- Yeah, that's so powerful
on so many levels.
I mean, and just to hear the outcomes too,
even though some of those
things weren't the focus,
but just having that
five-minute pause time,
how it had so many positive
effects in so many ways.
I'm curious, you know,
as I'm listening to you
talk through those things
and because a lot of
what we've talked about
has been on college and
university campuses,
I'm curious how much there's
a resetting of expectations,
'cause you even talked
about that from parents.
But one thing that I've
also noticed is sometimes
helping students reset
their own expectations
because sometimes they're
setting them too high.
- Yes.
- Or something that pre-COVID,
something that's not
attainable, falling short of it,
feeling guilty and anxious
they didn't meet those goals
and still, and then
getting stuck in a cycle
where they get further and
further away from those.
Are there any aspects of that
that you also see at
younger ages, as well,
even as you've talked about
the parents setting expectations,
what about the kids themselves?
- Oh, all across the board.
Their expectations,
they say fascinating of what do you need?
I guess the first thing is,
what do you need from your parents?
- Mmm.
- The number one thing
I get from the kids,
oh, is I,
"Would you please tell them
to just say that you love me for who I am
and don't quit asking me about the grade?
'Cause we are so worried about
letting our parents down.
I know they're worried about us,
but we are really, really
scrambling to get it together."
If you take one step more,
you can teach goal-setting to kids.
But goal-setting is, don't aim to here.
A good coach of an Olympic
athlete never said,
you're gonna get a gold medal tomorrow.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Watch your time today,
and you teach them one step more
and one step more and one step more.
Or you have a child who's overwhelmed.
Oh, my gosh, because of the anxiety.
So what you do there is you
tell 'em to chunk the task
and that is, let's look at it all.
Okay. Don't go worried
about the whole thing.
Let's do the first row or the second row,
or is there one thing on that whole sheet
that is your stumbler?
- Hmm.
- This example, I took piano as a kid
and Mr. White drove me to
early retirement on the piano.
- You still remember his name. (laughs)
- Oh, my God, Mr. White,
if you made one mistake wherever you were,
you had to start all over again.
So what I would do was
only focus on the mistake.
My stress level was so high
that I started to hate piano.
Bless Ms. Thompson, she
was my next teacher.
And what she had is a
whole different approach.
She'd identified my stumbler.
"So one little thing that's
getting in your way, Michele.
Let's just practice that little
bar over and over and over,
now you're fine.
Now start at the beginning."
Well, now I'm relaxed
and that's what a good coach does.
- Yeah.
- They never say, "You might as well quit.
You can't do it right."
No, let's look at the video.
Oh, your foot's going the wrong way.
Let's just practice your
foot going that way.
See, the goal is to take all those little
evidence-based strategies,
not 'em all
or your kid will never
let you read another book.
- Yeah. (laughs)
- One little thing at a time at time.
What works for you
until you can teach your
child to do it on their own.
Because the one thing I have discovered
about resilient children
is they have agency.
They don't wait for us to do it.
They finally figure out the strategies
and that's what we've
gotta help our kids learn,
is you've got it, but here's the strategy
that'll help you get it.
Practice and practice until
you can do it all your own,
then they'll use it the
rest of their lives.
- Yeah. That's so,
I mean, so many practical pieces there
that all seem like
they're a cultural shift.
I mean, like you said,
they're all evidence-based,
but because of the
performance being so ingrained
in our culture,
I think it's that much
more difficult at times.
- Well, I think the first step, you know,
is you can't change your parenting
or your teaching or anything,
unless you understand the why.
- Mmm, hmm mm.
- And I always tell the school.
I said, "The most wonderful
thing you could do is,
and it won't take any more than a minute
is give every kid a survey
and just fill out three things
of what's the one thing you
wish the teachers would,
what do you appreciate about the teachers?
What's the one thing you wished
appreciate about your parents
or wish they would do?
What's the one feeling that
you're having right now?
And anxiety, stress, overwhelmed,
always come up on the feeling.
The one thing they appreciate
about the teachers,
it makes them cry every time.
I just did this with
Jacksonville, Florida,
and they, the kids came up,
these were teens.
The lunch lady.
I love her 'cause she sings all day
and I walk into the lunch
room and she's singing.
The custodian 'cause he says,
"Have a good one, spike,
you're gonna do it."
The teacher who waits for me at the door
and says that simple, little things.
And then I looked at the parents
and I was frankly, I was like, oh my gosh,
what's the one thing you
appreciate your parent
or your family.
I can't tell you how many times "My dog"
came up on the list.
- Wow.
- My dog,
that my mom drives me to school.
It wasn't the things we said
that we've got to maybe have
some empathy for our children
because they're really hurting right now.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And that surveys are so,
I mean, even just the
naming it, as you mentioned,
which goes back to, on the one hand,
naming the things that are challenging
and naming the things that are giving life
and giving support.
- Yes, yes.
- At the same time.
So important.
So I also, I mean, I'll throw
a little bit of an oddball,
'cause this is a question
that I've been curious about
for some time.
Obviously, I know you focus
on the child development,
but one thing that,
again, just talking to kids
that seems to come up,
sometimes as I hear them kind
of talking about scenarios
in the schools and again,
the neuroscientist in me
automatically goes on to thinking,
well, these teachers are spread very thin.
- Yes.
- And I'm not sure the teachers
are actually attentive
to their own stressors.
- Yes.
- And irritants and things like that.
So is that something that
comes up in conversation,
even though I know you focus
on the child development,
- No, no.
- Awareness for the adults
who are in the class?
- It's such a critical, critical comment.
Because first of all,
we are losing an enormous
amount of teachers
who are retiring.
If there's one thing
every one of us should do
is write a thank you note to a teacher.
'Cause the reason that
they got into teaching
is because they love children
and they wanna make a difference.
Just writing 'em a thank you
is one of the best ways to reduce burnout.
Second of all is, at the end
of every one of my speeches,
I spend 30 minutes talking about
now, what are you gonna
do? Take care of yourself.
What's your one go-to that works for you?
I would suggest at schools that
you do more sunshine calls,
just, just taking time for each other,
collegiality, finding a support network.
What is working for you?
And in some cases,
the counselor has a
before-school yoga group.
That doesn't mean all
teachers are gonna do it.
For some teachers, they
say they really love books.
Bibliotherapy.
Getting into the shoes of a character
who's been through a tough time
and coming out to the other side,
reading the book,
"Educated", can be enormous.
Malala's books can be extraordinary
of here's a kid who
endured and got through.
It helps the teacher realize
resilience is something
that you're not born with.
You can acquire it and
we can help our children
and it's doable.
But once they begin to
realize you can do it.
I remember when I was
writing the book "Thrivers",
each chapter has a real story
about somebody who endured
and made it to extraordinary, tough time.
And I remember when I was
writing the chapter on empathy,
I was reading about Elizabeth Smart.
Here is a girl who went
through nine months
of absolute terror, kidnapped,
a knife in her bedroom
and then horrific horror of horrors.
But the one chapter that just,
it was the stop moment.
How did she endure it?
She said, "It was the
second day of captivity,
when all of a sudden
I remembered something
my mother said to me,
she came crystal clear
into my head and she said,
'Elizabeth, no matter what,
remember, I will always love you,
no matter whatever happens,
I'm always there for you.'
And I said, if my mother
is always going to love me
for who I am, I'm gonna
be able to get through it.
She says, that gave me the
fortitude to keep going.
- Wow.
Wow.
That's so powerful.
- Yeah.
So I think we forget those ordinary things
and it's like go home and hug your kid,
but tell 'em, "I'm here for
you no matter what happens.
I love you for who you are."
- Yeah. That's so, so easy
for us to slip outta that.
And I think that ties everything together,
what you've been talking about,
both from the kids and
from our expectations
as we all kind of get
spread thin in those places.
So, wow.
Just, I mean,
I just feel like you just
need just to pause there
and just really take that in.
'Cause I think that comment,
even though itself can go such a long way,
but the other thing which really stand up,
stands out from what you're talking about
is just the learning that happens.
The learning of the resilience.
Now you've talked about
that with empathy as well.
So I'd also wanna get to your new book,
but maybe to park on this
empathy piece for a little bit
and just have you elaborate
on what you've learned
about really teaching that
and how that can be developed
and kind of stick for the long term,
what are some of the principles
that have come up in your work?
- I think it was dealing with,
well, it was once again,
a moment that just changed my life.
It was sitting on a bench in
the Cambodian killing fields.
- [Addy] Mmm.
- And it was, I had a an,
because there, in front of me was a tree
because their in front of me was a tree
with these little ribbons on it.
And each ribbon stood for a child
who had been slaughtered on that tree
because they were crying.
Next to me was a monolith of
five stories high of skulls.
And that was, that President
was a former teacher
And that was, that president
who set the evil, so that's doable.
I couldn't believe it.
I happened to walk off the killing fields
and there was a little teeny table
that was selling a few books
and there was my, oh my gosh,
but I picked it up.
It was by Samuel Oliner,
one of the most amazing
social psychologists.
His family had been slaughtered in Germany
during the Holocaust.
He had a perfect woman,
just didn't know anyone or him.
Samuel was 12 at the time.
Her name was Bowinda.
She said, "Samuel, come in here.
I need to save you, run
as fast as you can."
His family went off to a death camp.
She saved his life,
and now the entire rest of his life,
he's trying to figure out what
makes Bowinda's of the world?
Not the evil, what flips the other side.
And what he did was extraordinary.
He's interviewed hundreds of rescuers,
Christians during World War II,
who risked their life
to save Jewish people.
"Why?" he said,
and the commonality that each
one of them were three things,
I call 'em the three Es.
Every one of them said
it was how I was raised.
Went, "Whoa, how were you raised."
The first thing was example.
They saw my dad or I saw my mom.
She always really was the
example of empathy or kindness.
The second thing was
expectations in our family.
You were expected to be kind,
you were expected to do good.
The third one was experiences.
My dad would walk it, my mom would say it,
but then we did experiences.
So we would deliver
overcoats to a needy family
or we'd bake cookies to
the neighbor next door.
Those three things
started to build empathy.
So each person said, I saw
myself as a caring person.
What the parents were doing
was changing the child's mindset.
So now they see themself
as a caring person.
You act how you see yourself to be.
And I think what we've done is
we put so much of our mindset into the GPA
and the test score
that when the kid comes
home, we rarely say,
"What good thing did you do?"
As opposed to, "What grade did you get?"
It doesn't mean you're gonna stop asking.
"Are you studying your hardest?"
But it also means, this
was I expect you to do.
The lesson from it all is that
empathy can be cultivated.
And the research now is
clear that our, we are,
our children are hardwired for it.
But unless we really make
it a little more intentional
in today's world, in particular,
it's gonna lie dormant.
And I, I swear,
after, especially after two
years of physical distancing
and looking at a screen,
as opposed to face-to-face,
because the pathway to
empathy is looking at someone
and going, "How would she feel?
How do I feel?"
That emotional literacy
piece starts the trajectory
towards I'm gonna reach out and help.
So those are the pieces you learned.
And that's why wrote "UnSelfie".
I went, okay, if this is doable,
then what are the habits
that we can start teaching?
And let's make it easy.
And I, one of the most critical ones
is besides instilling in your
child, the caring mindset,
we need to talk feelings far
more naturally to our kids.
We can watch "Inside
Out" with our older kids.
We can say, "How are you doing today?"
We can say, "Sit here
and watch dad's face.
And when he walks in
and you'll know if this is a good time
to ask him for the allowance or not."
Can be extremely wonderful moments,
but you can also, for some children,
they're a little nervous
about saying the emotion.
So you can do what an ER doctor says.
And he always says, how bad's the pain?
Show me with your fingers.
A zero is you could be asleep,
it's so, you're so relaxed.
A seven, you're about ready to explode
because the pain is so bad,
but you can do that with your children.
Your children can give
you, "I'm at a three, mom".
"Thank you for telling me, sweetie.
Let's figure out how to
get it to a two or a one."
You know?
- [Addy] Yeah.
- It's that empathy piece
of us trying to empathize with our kids,
is the starter point.
Then we start helping them learn emotions.
We start helping them
not see it in themselves,
but how would you feel
if that happened to you?
What is she doing in order to feel better?
What can you do?
You watch TV and it's just gloriously,
oh, just horrific stuff.
But you can also say,
what can we do to help?
- Mm hmm.
- Yeah. That's a good idea.
I know you're really upset by that.
But let's go collect some,
that's gonna keep a box by your back door.
It's a charity box for your family.
And it's for gently used toys and books
and whatever, backpacks,
and each time it's filled,
your family, not you, mom, dad,
your family delivers
it to someone in need.
Every child said it was the
look in the other person's eye
that said, "I gotta keep doing this."
- Mmm, mm.
That's so, so well said.
I mean, I love so many pieces of that.
Just the three Es that you shared too.
I mean, I've been
thinking about the example
and the experience together,
because as you're talking about parents
really tuning in with their children,
but then also having time to say,
as parents, well, this is what
I'm feeling in this moment.
And to have the kids also
learn from that example.
And again, you know,
I keep kinda moving back
to the college sphere
because that's a space that I live in,
but I've even seen that on
campus in a lot of ways, too,
with a lot of the social justice issues
that have been going on.
With students who have said,
"Oh, I've never heard my professors
actually talk about their
own struggles with this
- Oh, how sad!
- Or create the space
- Yeah.
- To have those conversations.
So as those things are
beginning to happen,
it seems like even though
this is a layer developmental stage,
there's places for people
to actually build community
and empathy with one another
because they can now both
see where they're coming from
and then tie into so many
of those practical outcomes
that you're talking about, as well.
- Well, I think the
trajectory from me to we,
and that's where we're aiming for.
Oh, I hope we're aiming
for us as a society
is to listen to other people's stories,
to realize how much we
have in common with them.
When a child says he's different,
now let's find out how we're the same.
It's too often that sped apart
and we are becoming so
divisive as a group.
We can't, we've gotta figure out,
look at the kind of books
you're reading to your children,
make sure that you're
reading different genders,
different races, different incomes,
different possibilities.
Because books,
books, literary fiction
are known to be able to
open up your empathy.
Ah, okay.
They also help you in terms of learning,
but you find the right book,
that's why "Wonder" is one
of the most popular books
for children right now.
- Yeah.
- Because they feel with that character.
- I ask middle school kids,
"What's the one book
that teachers should always,
always, always help kids read?"
And I'm blown away that
they say "The Outsiders".
I went, "That's 50 years old. Why?"
I love their answer
because we've gotta understand
what it feels like to be excluded.
- Mmm.
- How glorious to have that as an answer?
And that means that you're exposing kids
and then you're doing something
wonderful, like you did,
having the space to be
able to talk about it,
have those dialogues
where a kid knows it's okay to open up
and to be assertive
because that's another
trait of resilient children,
they have voice.
- Hmm, hmm.
Yeah. So important.
And I love, I mean, just
as we're talking through,
this is one of those,
I'm definitely gonna have
to go back and listen to,
'cause I think you're bringing
so many things to life.
And like you said, there's
so much evidence for it.
But to just to hear it in this context
and be reminded of it,
I think is so important.
There's so many practical pieces
that we can pull out of it.
- Thank you.
Well, that was the goal.
The goal was really after
listening to my dad,
I saw two huge needs and I think it was,
again, I started to do
focus groups with teens
and I never realized
prior to the pandemic,
how struggling,
they were struggling, they were hurting,
their anxiety, their stress,
even though were loved to death,
their opportunities were endless,
but something was really
amiss with the kids.
And then the pandemic hit.
Well, a crisis only amplifies
a preexisting issue.
And therefore the CDC
and the Surgeon General's
reports on mental health needs
are critical.
But it also means,
hey folks, we gotta reset
what we're doing here.
We have to reset what we're thinking.
And this is,
when I wrote the last one, "Thrivers",
was, empathy was what I did
was to choose the seven most
highly correlated strengths
that research and all the
work on resilience says
are teachable,
that will impact mental
health, resilience,
and peak performance.
Of course, number two
on the list was empathy.
'Cause I don't think you can
go anywhere without empathy.
But the first on the list was confidence.
The child needs to know who they are,
what their passion is that
we talked about earlier.
And we've driven that passion out of it.
Many kids said,
"We're being driven to be
what my parents want me to be,
not who I am."
I think that's so essential.
The third one we already talked
about too, was self control.
Unless you can figure out how
to put the break on impulses
and do that one-two breath
or whatever works for you.
Fourth is integrity.
That would be what
Samuel Oliner discovered,
those parents knew exactly
what the kind of kid they wanted
to turn out of that house.
In this house, we're gonna be kind,
we're gonna be caring,
we're gonna be socially responsible.
Empathy and social responsible
were the two highest
correlated values of a home
that raises a kid who's altruist.
- Wow.
- But they kept going
that over and over again.
And then the fifth one is curiosity.
We've helicoptered our kids to death.
We've solved every problem for them.
There goes the agency.
So curiosity is helping
the kid be creative
and open to ideas and possibilities.
So when the challenge comes,
you're not dumbfounded.
You figure out what am I gonna do instead.
Mom's not gonna help me this time.
She's gonna teach me how to brainstorm.
What's the problem?
What's one thing you could
have done differently
in another thing?
Sixth is perseverance.
Now you're gonna keep on going
because you've got all
these other little skills
along the way,
and you're gonna realize your effort
is what gets you moving,
not your GPA or your zip code.
And the final one is optimism and hope.
If we don't instill that in a child,
particularly in today's world
and the images that they're seeing.
After a while,
a lot of 'em are gonna
start raising a white flag
of I surrender, why should I do it?
And I give up,
that's not the kind of child we want.
We want a strong kid who knows
the world is gonna be okay.
And there's things that
you can do to make it okay.
- Yeah, and again, just
backed up by all the research
and tying that full circle,
especially ending with that hope,
as you mentioned before, too.
I mean, there's so many,
so many good things that you're doing.
I think there's a lot
that the listeners will
be able to digest here
and to re-listen to, as well.
And you've talked about this already,
but I'm curious to know,
with all these efforts,
what's the, what's the,
the piece that brings you
the most joy in this work?
- The kids.
I didn't realize 'cause
I was the, like you,
the person that was just reading
the research and research,
often this side, I've gotta pile this big
and I just keep reading,
and reading, and reading.
And then I'd go and talk
to the kids and I go,
"Oh, my gosh, that's exactly
what the research said!"
It's like, why don't we
just talk to the kids?
But they also have solutions,
simple little things that they suggest.
And so, there isn't a time
when I can be exhausted
getting off a plane.
But if I know I'm gonna do a focus group,
I get rejuvenated going,
"That's the next generation
and there's hope."
- Yeah. Yeah.
In some ways, I mean, even tying,
I'm tying back to your dad again too,
but you're building
community in so many ways
with all the lives that you're touching.
And it really just makes
me think about the way
that people invested in your dad
and do what you're doing
for others in the community
you're building around that, so.
- Well, thank you.
- Wow.
- It's been a joy, it's still a ride.
And the more we just turn on the news,
you realize this is more
relevant now than ever.
I think the piece that if
there's one takeaway here,
resilience is not a program and one trait,
I see that a lot.
It's not locked into your DNA.
This is something that
research says can be done.
It isn't an overnight process either.
So we can all relax.
This is a new thing of a new parenting
and educational plan that
we've gotta weave in.
And we weave it into,
not like at six o'clock, we're
gonna talk about resilience,
but we weave it into our discipline,
the books we read,
the talks we have with our kids.
We just need to be little more intentional
and know this is important
and we can do it.
Find one little tip you wanna weave in
and do that every day, a minute a day.
And I think that's how we
start raising stronger kids.
- Yeah. That's so well said,
that intentionality,
and as you emphasized
throughout one step at a time,
not everything at once,
but just really being able
to bake it in, in a sense.
And as a final question,
and this has been a joy,
just having you here for your
inspiration and encouragement,
where can people go to
find out more resources,
either about you, your books,
or just resources in
general around these topics?
- Well, my website is MicheleBorba.com.
I'm a one L Michele and
Borba rhymes with Zorba,
so there you go.
(Addy and Michele laughing)
"Thrivers" is the latest book
that will be out in paperback,
March 8th in digital form,
audio form, also paperback.
So it's,
I think what I tried to do is
make this nugget proof,
kind of simple stuff.
So ever hopefully, read
an entire book of mine
in one sitting.
Instead, crack it open.
There's a test at the beginning
of which of those strengths
is your children's strengths
or weakness.
Not you see it as a weakness,
but you see it as there's
where I'm gonna start.
And then just keep looking at it
as one particular ongoing plan.
The other thing I think we do wrong
is we try to do it ourselves.
Get a grandmother involved,
get the daycare worker involved,
pass it on to the teacher.
Here's the one little thing
I'm working on this month
and you'll always optimize
your gains with your child.
- Hmm. Yeah.
Great advice. Great advice.
Well, thank you so much for
being here on the "Addy Hour"
and for all the encouragement
and inspiration.
And this is the practical tips
that you shared with our listeners too.
I know this is one that
people will be grateful for,
and I think you're gonna be
able to share with others
and also listen to a few times to catch,
catch all these nuances
in some of these practical tips as well.
So thanks so much for being here.
- Oh, thank you.
Yes, too, you stay well.
- You too.
(upbeat music)